I'm Christian McHenry saying I'm the CEO  and founder of kennecott the motive this  part is really exciting for us it's the  first car in the world with one megawatt  of power that's 1,000 360 horsepower at  any given day at any given track no  other car can go faster at the same time  problem is to find a venue which I mean  you basically we need a 10-kilometer  straight to see how fast it can go  and then we have to turn around they go  the other direction which there aren't  many places on the planet to do that but  if someone asks us how fast is it well  it's most likely over 440 kilometers per  hour  we're very certain of that if we get  along enough straight  it looks quite certain it will be the  fastest car in the world but we don't  really want to focus on marketing that  side of the car because it's so unusable  to most people